[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to community Friday
except it's Wednesday it's a short week
so we're gonna do community Friday on
Wednesday and the idea this week was to
placed some Mario levels John Luke is
out of town so we're filling in and
Callie's taking the place of Ben because
she didn't play in a lot of Mario maker
I sure have level but yeah so I have a
couple stages that were submitted by the
community already that we're gonna start
with and then once we're through there
once they're through those a few stages
send us your stage IDs in chat and we'll
try to catch them and play some of those
stages yeah all right let's uh let's do
this all right I'm gonna turn it a
little bit like you said we already have
stages selected yep we've got a couple
and course IDs are there briefly if you
want to try playing them
this bother getting around the Cali you
just made a stage to Dania I did they
had a lot of fun yeah it's like a it's
kind of like a baby stage because it was
inspired by Yoshi's Story I really like
with snowy levels it's fun me too like I
have cheated I have played this one
before and I actually played all the
ones I picked before but after that
be surprised by some stages you guys Oh
God
I know that's kind of scary right yeah
hi to everyone in the chat definitely
leave us codes and we'll try to catch it
but hold off for a little bit cuz we're
gonna play the ones that Jake's arias
like maybe because I do want to get
through these ones that people sent us
just because they did send it to us
[Music]
starik this part where you have to like
hit the ball on stick it stresses me out
oh I like yeah if you're gonna leave it
I'd love a like a little like elevator
pitch for your course cuz we just got
Michael dragon 800 says want to try out
this poster to mine here Bowser's got
would've do I like that we got a little
bit of an elevator pitch so we know what
we're getting into
sort of
[Applause]
but Luigi gamer has coin challenge
number one I want to do coins number all
right let's get a a course from the
community in here um alright do you want
to do coin challenge number one why
don't we do the Bowser one since we
already called that one okay if it's not
too high up pal just got little dearie
read it for me wdv
ok LKG rjf although to be fair to Mike
was covering our um and again this is by
already go Michael VD can you be Bowser
it is deadly gauntlet full of obstacles
and enemies probably not I will try
though a little bit of puzzle solving
though that's good
I like when a level Ezz okay
well
I believe in you
alright should we give it like a certain
amount of tries like should we cuz I
don't wanna be stuck on a stage oh yeah
stream we do a 10 tribes are betrayed
someone says what happened to Jess just
lives in Australia and it is sleepy time
there
Bob Jones says three tries max octane
which okay but how about no like yes
tries like that time where I just booked
away a hide on a goof but right away I
feel like we could feel this out
Ben says three tries to splurge has some
third time is the charm but I pictured
that Ben I'm sorry
no thanks you can do this
I feel like I always fail in Mario when
I like get too stressed and like panic
you know yeah
hopefully I don't get like that it is
there's always like an extra layer yeah
[Music]
nice nice they're checkpoint nope oh
okay give it one more try bad job
I like the construction of the stage a
lot though this is like well thought out
I'll do like that you can a fire flower
like that yeah there's leash and fries
but like it's an extra
[Music]
[Music]
all right that's it for that one I tried
thank you Michael dragon I think that's
your name I'm sorry Michael dragon 800
thank you okay well like all of them as
well that we play okay you're gonna play
another one that you downloaded yeah
will do will do another that I
downloaded
this one's kind of Oh
Toad's Arctic expedition I like the
sound of that one
[Music]
oh this has lots of stuff going on
there's a lot going on here what in this
level
oh yeah
[Music]
there's a lot of fire flowers though so
it's like not
[Music]
[Music]
you did
[Music]
I guess one cuz it's like like we kind
of talked about like tweet that was like
focus on like it's on making like the
scenes yeah and this one feels that way
with like different walks
[Music]
and each one guy has like a different
theme to it
[Music]
yeah I like the you have to find the
switch
[Music]
I kind of cheese this part cuz you can't
jump on his head down there so I just
stay right here I think that's what
you're supposed to do right maybe
[Music]
hopefully I survived this jump
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
there was a checkpoint though that was a
checkpoint it's not too bad
[Music]
it's cool you're getting to play stuff
but like Nintendo would never do I know
right oh you have a microphone in front
of you yeah it's kind of in the way but
not that much of an excuse though
[Music]
[Music]
ran too fast
[Music]
again thank you guys for joining us for
community Friday on Wednesday
[Music]
that was ballsy that one that was should
not have done that but I survived I live
I I want to make a stage it's like sound
effects it's on stage that was um it was
musical notes and stuff and it was a
gourmet race from Kirby banger
[Music]
No
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well when he jumps up get up there
so I'm not sure
[Music]
I have a feeling that's not it but I was
stuck and couldn't figure out how all
right let's do it by caleb landry I just
like the sound of that a lot it sounds
like a it sounds like a Disneyland right
all right v TX 1 MF v YF alright alright
Godspeed a lot of pretty low clear right
so I love the sound effects you're not
the only one I like that you can see
where people fail on your stages so you
can kind of like take that information
and learn for your next day yeah
I have a feeling if you do like one to
over
or just back up I don't know I don't
know man yeah I don't know if I'm gonna
be making it past this part anytime soon
I think you just need to like go
stop yeah well I don't
I think I'd run into like all the spikes
[Music]
try once I probably won't make it
[Music]
nevermind sorry Caleb I don't think
we're skilled enough only at least see
if I can make a pass
[Music]
I gotta jump up and down is there like a
hidden block I don't know Caleb help I'm
always down for a snow level though
[Music]
I will give a like but I did not finish
that look at you another one since how
about this castle autoscroller and try
that okay this is by Abdul Paniagua
I'm so sorry 1 9 f h DM 9 2 H alright
[Music]
autoscroll great this should be easy
a simple stocking version 2.1 let's go
[Music]
he's gonna chase you he's the stalker
I think you can do this if it gets yeah
no I didn't
[Music]
oh wait they stay scroll a bit
[Music]
I like it so like you're having
international follow you
well I see that fire fire why aren't you
jumping on him more
[Music]
one more time
[Music]
we're also doing a feature on a spot
made stages are we filling the lava oh
cool bye
[Music]
easy
[Music]
that's not the one you can get
[Music]
should we move on
[Music]
okay not as cool as him falling in the
lava but
I was dramatic
[Music]
having met this nice
get it get it get it
[Music]
[Music]
nice nice nice
oh you fell in the lava - hey that's how
I win this
[Music]
that's gonna fall
I'm so stressed
[Music]
right I probably died there oh no
another enemy I don't have anything you
got this you got this you got this
[Music]
breathe okay I have a plan yeah yeah oh
it's ready okay but I'm just gonna count
that as you finished it all right oh
let's do 100 coin challenge number one
bye Louise gamer all right r4 ph6 5 KQ g
you got navigating the keyboard is the
the real game all right
Oh player 20 you might need to scroll
down a long time oh it's because that's
why yeah sorry guys we haven't been this
is nice
I thought people weren't commenting and
I was sad but it was really because I'm
sure I missed a lot of people saying how
bad I was anyway thanks for sticking
with us I thought everyone left I'm very
very very happy okay
hi Joe booth Bob Jones says you've been
doing great Jake I need to collect coins
and I just run Thank You Ben um are you
gonna do another one that you yeah why
don't we do another one of those I
almost got the record oh I think if I
hit those blocks at the beginning I'd
have gotten the record I see one that I
think might be a some serious speed
actually I that one seems cool all right
Joe you you look there's another one but
I like this one it's very it's very
intricate bad dungeon investment limit
[Music]
thank you everybody who submitted levels
so far obviously we wanted time to get
to all of them but it's very much
appreciated and hopefully like some
people in the chat like
feel free to try out some of the levels
you see while you watch yeah Star Wars
is by little and thank you for
submitting a little elevator pitches it
helps yeah the microphone is not an
ideal oh this is also if you like smash
bros i made an everyone is here level
using enemies that's Kate of Canadia
sounds really hard though then I am
interested to see what I want to make a
level call the clown patrol that has to
do with the clown car right I'm not sure
what the uh the main can see like the
use of vines here oh is the our pip is
blocking the amount of coins that we
have that's okay I think it's better to
have the timer
[Music]
right now it's zero all right I'll give
this stage although I had a lot of fun
creating a level in 3d worlds because I
got to see wall jumps I'm making a 3d
world level right now I it's like my my
level is like multiple my level has like
multiple routes and within one of the
routes there's a whole route
it's the branching thing yeah one of the
raps is that you fall down
[Music]
thanks Ben he's at 141 points sorry I
should be shouting laughing who Errol
says would be cool if they had a Yoshi
maker spin-off or like a Yoshi's Island
mode I agree totally make Yoshi stages I
just loved I really like crafted world
[Music]
[Music]
cyber shocker 4 5 5 says I want to have
a fire in FileMaker I won't insult a
maker but I know that it would actually
be really hard okay we're at 200 points
yes both star one two we are allowing
level codes so just to fit your level
with a little pitch and we'll try to
well make we'll do what we can
[Music]
yeah gentle that's what a gentleman says
they have that's all the dungeon crater
in like feature complete or anything but
a top down yeah I could be cool to be
able to build like an overworld too and
all that kind of stuff all right okay
let's do another community stage you
find let me see
how about Mario goes on a walk sounds
good that sounds calm this is by Pro
Mimar 64 which did affect my decision Oh
J to be 5bb 7rf all right Mario goes on
a walk I made it I made of course about
environment global warming I can't want
to see what that's about
all right I'll also interested in saying
everyone is here the bar is in full
[Music]
we're getting a lot of levels thank you
to everyone
I wish we could get to pleaded one do
you want to do a a wiggler bounce level
sure despite both star 1 2 2
it's called wiggler worlds
I actually really like bouncing on
enemies it's part of like my level that
I created was like bouncing on piranha
plant the Piranha creepers needed tricky
too because the ones that then move are
yv7t gee yeah I like the bouncing
bouncing on enemy's levels all right 5
percent clear right not bad I don't
think happy Canada Day to you it was
yesterday I think this music okay I'm
really into this so far I like this a
lot
watch out enough oh okay you're not
alone at all
cool though I like this a lot yeah and
this is a jam the song she just jump off
yeah you jumped right off the edge I
have the bad habit of holding down
sprint no I don't need it there you go
I like they get so mad uh John Luke
wants me to lower the pip a bit I feel
like I'm gonna ruin that John
wait the lot there's no lives counter
yeah yeah there's also no lives counter
it's just coins which that's why I
really like this one I feel like I need
to be faster okay one or two more tries
that's that's cruel this oh yes sorry we
don't have a queue we're just uh I'm
just thinking I want to get past this
part I like I like this level so far I
think this jump is just a little too far
for me though
[Music]
yeah we're just uh we're just kind of
picking I'm just kind of picking stuff
so I love I love stages with creative
names and creative ideas all right let
me try to get there one more time and if
I don't I don't get I liked the music
for this stage a whole lot all right I
like to try to get today okay Larry
I like this level a lot
[Music]
a good stage is all about teaching the
player how to how to play in my oh okay
she's a little bit I think you did
that's fair I like that one that one was
really cool wiggler worlds and for those
who care he ended with 33 coins nobody
I'm not trying to ignore you there's
just so many um okay I want to try where
is it everyone is here I want to try
everyone is here why five six XXL 2ff
good work Bo star
alright alright let's see what it is
this is by Azure 3 Phoenix in the chat
that sure is ok everybody so far the the
d-pad sometimes gets me like that I'll
be trying to jump and then I'll slide my
finger down a little bit yeah Jake uses
the d-pad
I like the fire flowers I just walk on
top here I like the stage because it's
not it's like the theme is cute sorry
Bob Joe wow they're probably I'm sorry
I don't even recall gasping oh wow that
was kind of sorry I'll try to be more
quiet it happens especially exciting
Mario stages like you're generous the
virus why did you go that way every
other time you got towards me star well
I like I need this game but I'm freakin
broke that's a mood cruel
[Music]
yeah Mario goes on a tear murder spree
who I should make a level called murder
spree Kilimanjaro
[Music]
that's fun
I'm gonna make a little murder spree I
decided all right
thank you as your three Phoenix um to
the great mario massacre of 2019 all
right let's see I'm gonna I'm gonna do
another one that was submitted I think
we're almost out of the ones that we're
submitted this one's by Spanky kids
[Music]
[Music]
those stars of make the murder spree
level about trying to kill a bunch of
boo-boos wall-e soo okay but just try to
chase you down Bob Jones I like grouchy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Mario Naruto rentec I was glad people
are trying
Erol x-games mode I'm glad people are
trying
[Music]
ooh cat Pelzer
oh that was cute
[Music]
I guess I do you think about like the
fact that you can make boss fight I know
I'm like I know that sounds down but
[Music]
this is really cool
mine's a lizard
oh yeah do you want to try the Star Wars
one sure I'm so sorry
[Music]
alright we will head back to course IDs
[Music]
ok hard to hear me maybe that's better
99 7 y 8t k9g I stopped you so you 100%
of the story military I have not done
that yet I want to do it before I
started making stages but then I got
impatient okay oh this is cute already
that's so clever
[Music]
I killed the pilot
this is thanks for coming Lukas whitey
sorry wouldn't have time to get to your
level cut DJ misses can you do a British
accent the next time you see the code
out loud this is really clever a lot I
like the idea of the pilot sticks his
head out and throws wrenches in he's
repairing the ship
[Music]
ben says this is really cool and not not
just because it's a nice level I don't
know if that's what I'm supposed to do
Star Wars works
but having so much to do
[Music]
yeah damn it
[Music]
jump further
Oh music duh that checks out I love that
screaming sound like oh so am i it's
like it has no reason to be in this game
I love it
[Music]
[Music]
Check Point would have been nice I think
like that's our biggest thing is we're
like add checkpoints friends yeah for
the checkpoint Illuminati
I like I like hard stages and stuff but
having a check points just nice because
it can be frustrating to have to replay
stuff he already did
hey dopey oh that was cool though I
really like that one we're doing well I
where did years ago where did your level
go okay let's try a fun puzzle for you
not insanely difficult either I'm sold
alright and 5g and no n5b o7 gy l 9g 0.9
oh my god
well labyrinth Omega I don't know
anymore I lost my ability to to be able
that's all whatever Greek not a lot of
people who have anyway I think I think
this is someone else's sick I love it
I'm not I think I think this is like a
troll stage that someone made to share
him
[Music]
how
[Music]
wasn't quick enough okay let's just move
on to global warming
yeah yeah that's nice try okay let's do
global warming because I I gotta know I
gotta know how that works seven six l 5f
8 3 HS I imagine this is my spider here
oh the lava Castle right
you're welcome Tokyo globe oh no
apparently it's collect the coins save
the environment 75 coins all the the sea
levels rising how do you make it to the
water level changes depends on the stage
but there's like an option lets you it's
like in the left side
[Music]
now we're in for a nice yeah fire ice
caps are melting and the sun's coming
for you that checks out checks out
others there's uh there's typhoons all
right I like the fishbone was nice touch
[Music]
hit the switch I really appreciate the
global warming thing Oh God
[Music]
all right okay that's a cool theme I
want to try this one though because this
is a really cool idea Ben Brown says I
made a working vending machine with
challenges accompanying each available
power up all right and this was really
cool
that's one f7y m02 xf x is covered all
right how much more time do we have you
think maybe like 20 more minutes or so
yeah right
probably thirty minutes actually usually
these go 90 minutes or so I'm excited to
see this
oh yeah that's a cool enemy for sure
I don't know hello knows their way to
jump it kind of makes me think I got
played I don't see any any help
yeah tic-tac you just drop her token
Chatwal will um oh yeah you're stuck
will uh do you are best to get to levels
lots of effects
come on dragon come on where are you
hurry up hurry up nice dog guy so they
the other key though that guy dropped
and if I get in there I can't oh I knew
throw fireballs at them that's pretty
cool oh you need to rethink I'm screwed
alright that's cool
it's cool if I had more time I'd figure
it out um we're getting so many courses
here yeah we are getting a lot there was
one okay I like this because he beetle
bully buzzy beetle bowling alley by
Brandon birch it's rated 5 stars KP f VG
9 f - f all right
my flooded castle level that would be
pretty that sounds like course not found
did I enter it wrong Oh where'd it go
perhaps kpf VG 9 - f - f hmm I got it
right I guess that codes not right then
oh sorry Brandon birch um let's try
where to go the flooded Castle level
alright I'm having mouse problems flood
account right there
okay first to play by total 105 its kw0
okay alright 4 3 9 y 4g
flouted castle alright 0% clear right Oh
we'd be the first to play move quicker
I like these kind of stages though sorry
I feel like I'm trying to read the chat
but also talk but yet thank you for
sharing stages once again
thanks for sticking with us as we try
out different stages and if we don't get
to your stage we're really sorry we only
have so much time and I know it's okay
you got a checkpoint it was f2h can you
give us the full the full code then oh
yeah we'll try to get into it yeah it's
too much I will have a hard time finding
it I don't know what this button is
supposed to do I really love the pitch
for the buzzy beetle bowling alley is
rated 5 stars go to the code to knock
down these pins make sure to wear a blue
butyl helmet for safety so we don't get
sued
[Music]
um Ethan Miranda there's no queue I'm
just kind of selecting stuff based on if
it sounds interesting sounds fun sounds
like something that we personally can
play because we are not professional
speedrunners and we don't really like
troll levels because we like to have fun
[Music]
there's a pipe down there maybe
[Music]
[Music]
nice that's a special reward hey I like
that take it ok you got to move fast now
[Music]
alright alright nice job okay let's uh
let's get the buzzy beetle bowling alley
going alright KP f o VG 9 f 2h I like
themes I think they're fun I also I
really do like meeting fast but I'm I
don't know if I'm I feel like I'm good
enough to make as like a stage like that
yeah I feel like it takes a lot of time
to make some
need two feet Piranha Plants there the
pins okay I see
[Music]
that's cool
what if you
well they're not gonna move
[Music]
that's cool all right got him one more
time
[Music]
there's one we'll go back to this one
so I see
you skip the tutorial one yeah so there
are six which you can't see but there
are six piranhas yeah you can see the
one out of six you just get to the
problem all right
I already did this one chats going
really fast so I'm sorry if I missed
your stage oh this is cool
I people call this clever ideas I'm
worried about it
[Music]
all right gotta jump bro it you gotta
get really into boiling you gotta do it
who do you think you are I am like I
have my helmet for protection though
don't I get sued
darn I don't know how to angle that
[Music]
[Music]
just gotta figure out that angle
[Music]
here maybe sit back a little bit
[Music]
stand on pipe don't jump some of those
oh there was okay I figured out the
angle I think I was like right here and
you were on top of this way Tori I
[Music]
forgot the angle good well I'll do this
for like another minute and if you can't
get it
[Music]
[Music]
also don't hit it right away I know I'm
[Music]
didn't make it anyway
[Music]
okay this is a really cool idea but it's
difficult
[Music]
let me like it
Oh weird well thank you Brandon um okay
let's see you want to do 3d world
walljumps sure cuz I'm great at wall
jumps I kinda want to try this one seven
four nine okay 5 3 5 f 3 sorry D 3G
which we get for lunch
don't get cocky you wanna try first
mhm alright I like wall jumps probably
better than I am at them as well
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
I can do this I can do this that's
correct
[Music]
I like the rainbow in the background Oh
Mike you know what your injury I feel
for Jake right now
[Music]
[Music]
I know so far oscillating like us all
along mm-hmm I really like stuff to jump
off a building meets you here he said
jumping off out of movies that's family
okay what's your favorite enemy I like I
also like goombahs just because they're
under fighting five is as many console
game reviews OAH missions by Paulus
aiming thank you again
I keep saying it but thank you know I
think I'm making dumb faces watching you
[Music]
I give it one more shot
[Music]
dopey I wants to know what's our
favorite letter favorite letter yeah I
assume of the alphabet oh I thought he
meant like letters that had been
delivered to me oh no I like that course
dear sister oh I can still like it I
can't wait can't I I was gonna say cue
Errol there we go that's no that's not
like that's just filtering to see who
liked it oh I did like it already are
you adjusting a baby outfit yeah okay
see nice we should I do a couple more
hi everybody who's just joining us okay
let's see ooh do you want to try
spelunking in the Koopa mine uh sure
for this is by Sir Patrick sin' 4bk r-13
his are right behind like them my vrg
there's like this whole like third of
the keyboard that depending on which
angle I'm looking at a block different
areas all right are you brave enough to
enter the mine well then good luck yeah
let's do it let's do this I look cause
we carry you and I'm not sure what the
rest of that statement is about man - C
D G and is e then probably understands
[Music]
Abby Jamison thank you yeah I kind of
hate the sound he makes when you start
running but like it's like us okay bent
aside question Hyuk is it to walk ran
out Luigi gamer
thanks for something more we already did
one of yours bill and I want to make
sure we do different people stages so
unfortunately not going to do another
coin challenge but I do like the coin
challenges
I think they're fun it's always
satisfying to get coins I feel like okay
I like this pitch for the next stage
because they specifically say it include
the chicken
I like this stage oh oh I got hit twice
that's a bummer let me try one more time
[Music]
I like a cute megaload on which first of
all is a great name says I call PETA why
are you killing one more time more time
[Music]
cyborg man I don't know if you're in the
u.s. we have a holiday tomorrow like
which is just an excuse no drinking
barbecue really I myself I'm gonna have
no burger that's my whole plan
but yeah so we don't have work tomorrow
or Friday so we're doing CD Friday
mercilessly walks are it looks like you
only minecraft when you mind stephannie
see what I've got a hammer now I can
start breaking things
[Music]
Erol Anime Expo is this weekend I'm not
actually going I'm knocking you swing
hammer builder box
no blocks ok mineral veins thanks Ben
you know it's essentially Friday so I
don't need anyone
yeah I was gonna say but I wasn't sure
yes sir Patterson's like drop pound
what's my favorite anime I it's always
hard for you to pick a favorite anything
I'm excited for Pro soiree and some food
what I want to say killer killer watch a
good let's go see oh that's so cute
just let it kill you i I over some peas
and I like freaked out about thermal
twister jump
don't worry at all I think I beat the
stage because I want to jump up great if
I angle myself I'm gonna hate this bike
I see there's a method to my madness is
the I shouldn't be backseat gaming so
much I hope everyone if you are in the
US have a nice animals don't smoke
cigarettes around propane I really like
that that's cool spelunking in the coop
of mine let's see how about Ethan
Miranda has one called boxes which I I
like the the mystery of that so we're
going to try that one ml R 0 B 0 all
right let's do two more and we'll call
it WTF I don't know why I said it like
that let's go oh you're gonna do a
British accent cool one clear of 1300
tracks thousand tries all right Ethan
marina Maisie says how long on average
does it take to make a level it took me
2 days I mean I didn't spend two
straight days do you also like restarted
I didn't totally research I redid the
beginning middle which a lot of people
died there it doesn't depend on the
bubble you're thinking they can't do it
now I have to get that thing in yeah
like I would highly recommend just like
playing around with it I really thought
like I'm not I'm not good enough I'm not
creative enough to do this but I am
really I don't know if this is gonna
this is gonna happen
yeah oh you can long jump
doppio says it takes exactly four hours
five minutes and 30 seconds Franklin
checks out that's fair all right all
right
thank you for sending that in Ethan
Miranda but a little too much right now
we eat something
I appreciate that I appreciate the heat
okay let's see let's try like a you want
to try the 3d World 60-second speedrun
sure by tick-tock 85 kfm md7 r1g this is
a troll tho 2% or Shaq gaming we don't
finish the courses because we don't have
all day and we want to make sure we show
off a lot of different people's courses
yeah but hey all these courses are here
if you wanna finish up they're there for
you to play
I think I've been a little slow at the
beginning sorrowful making and I just
did that after I ran through I got
nervous Harvin I like all right I want
to give that another try
you do that one thesaurus Rex dopamine
[Music]
super fan says those spikes give me
phobia
they both have the spikes and like
peanut phobia like lots of little holes
I forget what to call right now that's
something a lot of people have I was
worried about I was like I know I
shouldn't jump Ohno I think I was so
close - yeah it's like triple phobia we
can do this we got this Alex's level a
lot I'm not biased with the cute mice
make a level with the mice deer jumps
who like that game echo for the AI last
week oh no no I know
[Music]
have a fun holiday weekend Abby thank
you for coming I think you're just
supposed to same one one more time then
we'll try another one one more time then
we'll see one more and then we have to
[Music]
[Music]
I'll ike this one cuz you can barely
[Music]
I like the tennis teammates on those I'm
like little glass pipe sleeping oh no
all right that's cool all right one more
let's see you want to do Hollywood Tower
of Terror sure um this is by Mario nice
fh7 xgq oops
where'd it go m0h I like this because I
really liked the Tower of Terror before
they got rid of it in California
Adventure it's got a pretty solid clear
right I think I should be able to get
through it hopefully yeah maybe um see
mr. Krabs thanks for coming by yeah
spoopy it's so cute I like that music I
think you're just too scary for me I
like the way you made windows out of the
icebox that's cute again we're very
sorry if we couldn't get to your level
oh that's cool I got it just kidding oh
[Music]
this is really cute I like this a whole
lot I'm gonna chat I jumped up in yeah
we are getting lunch after this I didn't
have breakfast so that's why I'm
thinking about what is a menu this is
really cool
yeah this is
[Music]
does look like a sick Oh the claws are
chandeliers oh there we go oh I just
stay in the center all right three
gaming Mario kids already had launch
yeah their chandeliers that's so I
really think this is clever I think you
can avoid those I think so too
[Music]
anyway
[Music]
the yell is one of my favorite sound
effects it might just be for decoration
[Music]
it's got a definitely got a cool
Twilight Zone vibe there's anything oh
those are the floor numbers what the
floor numbers are written in poised like
[Music]
a Wilhelm scream
Oh thought I could run through it one
more time one more time how much I see
this through
hi goob don't submit Simon's like oh god
I thought this was game stop that's okay
all of our family members for Game Stop
[Music]
game stopped by our games
[Music]
good to see you good we miss you welcome
to community Friday on Wednesday all
right I wanna see the floor numbers
yeah doppio we getting well we uh
pearlies yesterday's phone at burritos
okay all right
mostly simple just gotta watch out for
that who's the bearded weirdo don't know
him
[Music]
Mario and it's actually a mustache right
here yeah dude
nice nice nice
all right I'm not gonna bolt through
this yeah Ernest hops number 69 it has a
good point where that checkpoint at
Jake's things was this thing with games
to see who gets a little impatient so I
suck at seed what you thought I was
gonna hit the music no way
alright that was awesome washer that was
awesome
I really really liked that little lot we
got some awesome levels yeah thank you
everyone for seeing those levels sorry
we didn't get to all of them but
hopefully we do something like this
again because I think community Fridays
are Wednesdays and Mario maker goes very
well together yeah and thank you for not
putting any swears in your levels we
really appreciate that we're what
anything else we need to say before we
sign off nope we won't be here as we
said before there won't be any stream
Thursday or Friday because it is the
holiday for us but we'll be back Monday
with another stream don't know what
it'll be but we'll see and then next
Friday we'll have another GameSpot
community stream yeah on actual Friday
mmm may not be John Luke but I'm pretty
sure Ben will be back for that at least
yeah and if you want more Mario maker
levels we also have a feature on you
spot made levels and I think on the
written side we'll be doing a feature on
like personalities and game devs who
made levels like the celeste dev made
level the Doki Doki Motors your club
dive made a level so look out for that
stuff if you're interested in playing
some curated levels that we've been
picking out yeah we'll see you on Monday
have a great long weekend if you are
celebrating if not have a good rest a
week
[Music]